- A modern stock exchange isn't
people yelling at each other
to buy and sell things.
It's a matching engine,
a computer system that
takes in all the information
of who wants to sell, who wants to buy,
and what prices they want,
and then pairs them all up,
and exchanges money and shares
automatically as fast as it can.
Over the last couple of decades, though,
something called
high-frequency trading appeared:
computers trading on a stock exchange
faster than any human ever could,
watching for price fluctuations
and reacting instantly
before anyone else can.
The faster they react, the
more money they can make,
so companies collectively spent billions
on moving their equipment closer to
or even inside the exchange,
or building private
microwave and cable links
that send signals faster than anyone else.
One of the strategies
was to see someone else
send a trade request
and then get the same offer
to the exchange faster,
buy the shares first,
and then sell them on
for a tiny, tiny profit
thousands and thousands
and thousands of times.
Each microsecond advantage
could mean more profits.
These days, though, so many companies
have spent so much money
to get those tiny speed gains
that they're all trapped in a stalemate.
They're all as close to the
exchanges as they can be,
and the signal routes are
as close to light speed
as they can possibly make them.
When everyone's bought the
same expensive advantage,
no one's in the lead.
There is another solution, though,
and it's being used by
another stock exchange
a couple of blocks that way.
- IEX is now a fully-fledged
stock exchange,
so a lot of people obviously know names like
New York Stock Exchange and NASDAQ.
We're regulated and established the
exact same way as those stock exchanges.
We're one of 13 in the US.
Sometimes, people will take the argument
of 'high-frequency trading is bad'.
What we'll tell you is, there's nothing
wrong with those strategies,
but different than any
other stock exchange,
what we've done is we level the
playing field for not only those folk,
but also for the slow traders,
the human traders,
and the only way in which
you can really do that
is actually, as an exchange,
to slow things down.
Generally, in the US,
you're obligated to know
what's going on in all markets,
so the only way in
which you can do that is
you have to connect to
all the other markets,
you have to take in all
these super-fast feeds,
and you have to make a determination
on the best price at that time.
If someone can take in that information
quicker than the exchange
they're trading on,
then they can pick off people
trading on that exchange
before the exchange even
knows what the new price is.
We can take in all that data,
we can make a determination
on what the fairest price is,
and as long as someone is not
350 microseconds faster than us,
we will always have the clearest snapshot
on what the true price is in the market,
which is key.
The biggest proponent of delay
is something called propagation delay.
Just means the further away
you are from the signal,
the longer it takes you to get it,
so we said, why don't
we introduce distance?
350 microseconds is 61 kilometres.
We called up a fiber-optic provider,
and we asked them to coil cable for us,
and we had them fabricate this box.
This is actually 38 miles of cable.
It looks like three big fishing spools,
so anyone who wants to
trade on our exchange
has to come in and traverse this distance.
The high-frequency guys can be fast,
and that's totally fine
with them being fast,
but because physics is physics,
they'll never be 350 microseconds
faster than us,
so we can always ensure that we give
our clients the fairest price.
The filing to become a
stock exchange for IEX
was the most controversial filing
of any stock exchange ever.
All the negative comments were around
'you can't possibly introduce
a speed bump into the market'.
'It's going to cause a
calamity in the markets.'
'Everything's going to explode.'
But in any case, we did get approved.
I always found it funny, like in a market
that has billions of dollars
of technology invested into it,
the most talked-about thing
is IEX's exchange filing
and a piece of equipment worth $27,000,
but this $27,000 literally has
billions and billions of dollars
notionally trade through it every day,
and trade at the fair price.
So, it was worth the battle.
We did get approval,
and the SEC two years later
put out a white paper
saying not only did the calamity
not occur in the market,
the market overall, not just IEX,
has been more stable since
IEX became a stock exchange.
- Sure, you could do this by
having a computer receive every signal,
wait for however long you want,
and then send it on.
It would probably be cheaper.
High-grade fiber-optic cable
is expensive stuff,
but that would be another system
that could crash, or fail,
or be defeated somehow.
It's unnecessarily complicated.
There's a lot to be said for a solution
that just uses physics.